hello everybody and welcome to my
motorcycle for Lego video this is
actually an older video I made it quite
a bit ago but I want to go ahead and put
it up on this channel as well so enjoy a
little bit of background this was
actually done about two years ago isn't
done in February of 2010 I was I was in
college and I think it was a sophomore
in college and had been unemployed but I
you know I did a lot of ebay merchanting
and flipping and stuff among other
things to make money but I was still
running kind of low on money and so I
decided to expand my horizons a little
bit more and one of the markets I saw
room for profit in was flipping Legos
and just looking at the prices on ebay i
saw you could get you know bulk amounts
of legos for about like six to eight
dollars a pound and if you made it all
pretty and sorted it you get about ten
dollars a pound and so then I decided
well maybe I'll maybe I'll do that um
that's actually pretty difficult to make
money flipping on ebay because you have
to you know at the ending costs of
flipping on ebay is either nine percent
or eleven percent right off the top once
you include the final sales fees and
paypal so anyways it's pretty hard to
make money but I saw that and I thought
you know that's a decent way to make
money so I started up this little
itty-bitty business of flipping Legos on
ebay and I posted a thread on a
motorcycle forum that I was on thinking
you know most of these guys they're in
their early 20 so chances are they had
Legos you know they're really popular
they're still kind of popular now but
they were really popular when I was a
kid and these people were kids so
figured there'd be a lot of people on
that on these motorcycle forums the had
Legos and probably just didn't use them
anymore and wouldn't mind the money so i
posted up a thread and um i'm in about a
week or so maybe less i can't i can't
really remember but it was pretty quick
somebody contacted me and they were like
hey look my brother he's got you know
bunch of legos
and I'll definitely get you in touch
with him you know so then we started
talking me and this guy's brother and
the guys like you know I've got a I got
a lot of Legos and he sends me some
pictures and I'm like oh my god I mean
he had this huge Tupperware a drawer
system that had it just a everything was
already sorted it was like he had a
bunch of the little characters and stuff
I think he had it was something like 200
sets and he had like binders full of the
instruction manuals and stuff and he had
a lot of the original box is I mean this
was the most meticulous set I've ever
seen in my life and and you know I
wasn't prepared to to buy all that he
wanted to sell it for i think he said he
had put it up on ebay for me like four
or five thousand dollars or something
like that you know he just wanted to
sell it all and i said well i can't
afford it all I don't have that much in
cash you know and he was like yeah I
just don't really want to part it out
because I was hoping to be able to take
parts at a time and sell them but he
didn't you know and rightly so want to
split up the sets and or you know that
massive collection so he didn't want to
do that and I said well the only thing I
have that's a value is my motorcycle you
know and he's like well take that and
I'm like oh god you and and at the time
the motorcycle uh it was actually a
really nice deal that I got on the
motorcycle alone it was about it was a
2006 model and it ms r peed for about
seven thousand when i bought it it only
had three hundred miles on it and I got
it for thirty five hundred dollars so it
was actually a really good deal on the
bike already but that's about the bike
was worth after I'd put I that by this
point I think I'd put on about 10,000
and on a motorcycle anything you know
15,000 is pretty average anything over
30 thousands like a hundred thousand
miles on a car so anyway at the time the
motorcycle was worth about 3500
legitimately if i sold it and but this
guy
was like you know yeah I'll he was
interested in taking a flat trade just
the motorcycle for the Legos and so you
know I thought about it for a day or so
and and just you know I felt like you
know well i'm pretty sure i can get ten
dollars a pound and if it's really 600
pounds then I mean that's six thousand
dollars so you know twenty five hundred
dollars more than this motorcycles worth
or even if I could sell the motorcycle
for four thousand dollars still two
thousand dollars and so I decided to go
through with it my initial plan was to
actually part to like put the sets
together and sell the sets on ebay
because it was worth more like 12,000
for someone if they did that but but I
also knew I could probably sell the
whole thing in bulk and so so I ended up
accepting the offer and I accepted it on
I believe februari 15th and I got to
work I had him in my eye living
apartment at the time and so I get him
out on the ground and I started putting
together a set it's probably my mistake
I started putting together this huge
death star model or no I'm sorry what
was it shoot what was it the it was this
lego star wars destroyer and after
putting that together for a few hours I
realized oh my gosh I can't do this and
so I ended up just putting the whole set
on ebay and had a put up the whole set
in a or best offer and within a couple
days really I got a six thousand dollar
offer for the entire set and after like
I said after a mere day of putting that
stuff together I realized that was not
for me and so I ended up accepted the
six thousand dollar offer plus five
hundred dollars of shipping and so we
ended up going through with that and
yeah
I can't quite explain the feeling I can
try to describe it but after having we
load we unload this guy's truck he shows
up in this truck full of Legos we unload
his truck and put all of these Legos get
them all into my my apartment and we
load up the motorcycle into his truck
that's that sign the bill of sale and
shake hands and they're on their way and
I go upstairs they're still making sure
everything's tied down and I'm looking
out the window at my motorcycle in this
guy's truck bed and then you know as
they start driving away and I see them
you know gone and I I turn around to a
an apartment basically full of Legos and
I just can't quite put it into words
what that feels I think but that's a
very strange strange feeling to know
that you traded your motorcycle for a
ton of Lego so anyway um yes that was
odd but it ended up turning out quite
well um literally just a four-day flip
for twenty-five hundred dollars not too
shabby for anybody's interested the
motorcycle was a kawasaki ninja 650 but
anyway here are some pictures this is
the bill of sale I blocked out my last
name and I also blocked up the buyers
last name I don't think he really wants
to be on YouTube and then also some of
the vin because again i don't think he
wants his bike on youtube although
people don't tend to open motorcycles
very long so maybe he doesn't even own
the bike anymore um yeah those sales
kind of funny is straight like these
bill of sales that you get online like
you just type in bill of sale and I
guess it just wasn't prepared for 2010
we sold the bike in twenty thousand and
ten but yep anyway um that's that
i just thought i would share that with
you guys I think it's pretty funny this
is all so this is the ebay listing it
was up there you can't really find it on
ebay anymore they've you know they just
don't keep that stuff for as long but I
did I kept in contact with the woman who
bought it and she told me whenever the
truck pulled up she was like why today
why is it in a truck I don't understand
because the picture really doesn't do it
justice you didn't you don't quite see
how much Lego this really was i mean
that's a raised bar really and you can
see the binders that was all the
instruction manuals and you can see a
little Tupperware containers and stuff
and then those bins are just full of
legos but you still don't really
understand how much Lego that really is
until you see it in person but anyway
when she got it she immediately called
me it was like oh my god this is so much
leg up and and she was real happy and I
forget what she said she ended up
selling mean she parted everything
together kind of like what I was doing
but that was she was much better at I
guess she had a whole room in her house
dedicated to putting Lego together and I
think she told me I mean over twenty
thousand dollars is what she made
putting it together and I believe it
because they're everything like I said
they were they all the construction
manuals were in there and there was like
this excel sheet of all the sets and I
went through and looked up each of the
sets on ebay and price num and it was a
lot of money you could made a lot of
money putting it together but who I was
definitely not that wasn't for me this
is the receipt from the shipping company
the shipping was actually a huge ordeal
it was really difficult to find somebody
that would ship this because the weight
was too high for the obviously postal
service UPS FedEx none of them would
ship this for me I believe UPS and FedEx
would have if that was if I had a
commercial address but for whatever
reason because like they would only
deliver for businesses that wait for
business
is not for a resident I'm not quite sure
why they do that but that's the case and
so I had to find a bulk shipping company
that would like do this for me and so as
you can see the date of this receipt
here is actually March second which is
me weeks after the final sale of the
Lego luckily the buyer was pretty
patient with this whole thing and I
believe shipping actually turned out to
be more than five hundred dollars and
she still paid it so that was really
nice of her um yeah shipping was just a
pain i think they took like two weeks or
something just to even get to her like
they kept i guess a truck i can't
remember what the story was the guy was
telling me he's like oh well one of our
truckers uh got sick or something like
that i'm like well you guarantee because
i think we shift it with like a two-week
guarantee or something like that and it
didn't make it you know it was that was
kind of annoying so i would not
recommend packing send i'm not even sure
if they're still in business so anyway
that concludes the classic motorcycle
for lego technic as always thank you for
watching thank you for your support your
subscriptions and until next time